Hey Jim, so you are the first one today.
Yay! Well, you're the first one. Good.
How's it going?
No, no, Karen's going, Karen always joined prior like 2 to 3 minutes.
She likes to start early, yeah.
Yeah, is she not in today?
She's away from her desk. Let's see here.
I do. She's away.
Just away from her desk at the one she's definitely here today.
Okay.
Everyday Sunday.
So, how are you?
Doing pretty well. It's like too, you know, very hot over here today.
Our weather is all over the place, where...
Yeah, there's a heat wave going on.
It's raining; always have to translate to Celsius for you guys, so it is a typical spring day.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
We're at 18 degrees C today.
And drizzly, yeah.
Eighteen.
That's so much fun. Hey, Alex, how are you?
Comfortable.
Ohh.
Hi, Mohit, how you doing, man?
Hey, Alex is here.
I'm so glad to see you.
What's going on?
Hi, Alex.
Alex seems pretty busy today. I can see that you feel a bit off, like tired. Everything okay?
Hey, Jain.
No, I'm fine. I'm tired, yes. Yeah, doing good.
The.
Yes, I can see that.
Doing good. Thank you. Thank you for pointing that out. I appreciate it.
Yu.
But.
It's always the best way.
Do they have something to eat? Like, do they have something to eat? Like...
I ran out real quick because I needed, I was passing out, I ran out to get some lunch and I was trying to find something really fast. So I went to, I went to Wendy's and because it's very close and ended up taking 40 minutes for me to get my food.
Yes.
Mhm.
And.
Oh my goodness, that's crazy.
I was waiting in line, the drive-through, you know, line. I actually called Wendy's corporate headquarters while I was waiting in line and they refunded my order.
Mhm.
Yes.
Yeah.
And then I, they gave me a, they gave me a $15 credit, you know, while I was waiting in line.
Ohh, yeah.
But it was on spot at that point.
On the spot, yeah. I tried to tell them, I'm like, listen, you guys gotta hire more people at this one.
It's ridiculous. It's a big problem. They locked the doors. Yeah, yeah, I think yes, one by Planet Fitness. I went ahead and I punched in my order and the mobile order and I was going to do carry out, you know, and then I got there and the doors were locked.
Is that is that the one I play Planet Fitness?
OK.
Yeah.
Mhm.
What?
And I can only I could only get in the drive-through line, wait in the drive-through line to get my pickup order. And so and I knew I could tell it was going to be long because the line was long and it wasn't moving. But I got in line anyway. And and then I called corporate and I, you know, gave him the store number or order number. I said, you guys got a
No.
Mm.
problem. And they gave me a $15 credit. So I got the lunch for free, basically. But it was hard. I don't have time for that. I don't have time to wait 40 minutes. So
Right.
Obviously, you get the refund for the suffering, not for the lunch.
For quote unquote fast food. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, so I had to eat that very, very fast, and...
Yes.
Oh yes, I did eat mine. How about you? Did you eat? Good.
Yes, I had my dinner because it's dinner time. I didn't have much, but yes, it was plenty. So I'm good.
Okay, good.
Hey, Karen, we were waiting for you. Me and Jim would like...
Kour.
Yeah, sorry about that.
He.
Do I look tired, Karen? Well, it says I look tired. Oh my God. All right.
Yes.
Yes, you do.
Yes, yes, on spot.
I think you look fine, Alex.
What can I do about that? Do you see that? Are you saying the bags under my eyes? Is that what it is? My bags are permanent now. They actually became permanent. So there's nothing I can do about that.
Yeah.
No, no, no, Alex, it's also about your energy. We are aware about your energy and today you're like, okay, you suffered from like delaying and all that, so I understand.
Uhh.
No, my gosh.
The.
Yeah.
Okay, well, meeting's over. I'm good. Bye.
A.
Okay, thank you very much, ladies and gentlemen, for joining the call today. So I'll be...
You thought I was joking? Yeah, I came back.
I'm aware, I'm aware, Alex, that you'll be here.
Yeah.
OK, without further much ado, I'll share the screen.
Go ahead, this is your.
Ohh boy.
Okay, we'll also have discussion regarding animation and Vincent. Okay, so the subject that I'm representing is for two weeks that will be totally focused on Shivani and her deliverables, as I got to know that Vincent is actually working on that, but was not filling up the utilization and taking time on the time entries on the tickets.
Ohh.
So just let me know wherever we need to provide a feedback or anything that's required, Alex, Jim, or Karen. Okay. I hope the screen's visible to you guys.
Okay.
Yes.
You're on mute.
No.
Thank Yu.
Thank you very much for joining the call today. So the agenda for today's call would be our partnership, the value drivers, team data, way forward, and any queries to do.
So moving with the value drivers, as we are a very scalable cost factor service delivery, I'm about the conversation, Alex. So we are looking out for new resources as well, as same as level as Shivani as well, right? So I do think the strategic flexibility is coming into the play and we are enabling you to add more resources, provide more deliverables and other things as well.
But if there is anything else apart from that, please feel free to share with us so that we can work collaboratively toward that same goal.
Now let's move on to the service delivery utilization for Shivani for the time period from 13th of April till 20th, till yesterday.
Do you want me to add it, Alex?
I already did.
Thank you.
Khanna.
Thank you very much.
So if I talk about the peak utilization and the trend that we have seen, so 77% has been the average for Shivani for.
and she has catered along like for more than eight key partners, most of the tickets for eight key partners. We have seen a trend after Vincent joined, we have seen a drop of utilization and there were not much tickets as well. So that's what we have observed from our end, but any feedback, anything from your side will be really appreciated.
So if I see that she maintained a strong baseline for both of the weeks with a standard average of 77 percent, but yes, please feel free to, you know, let us know if there is anything that's not on the track.
Moving on to the next.
For the time period, Vincent joined on the 15th, and after that, I see a drop of tickets as well and the utilization as well for Shivani. And after that, we see a peak of 77% on 24th.
If I talk about the client that she was adhering to, that was Council of Southeast, National Forensics, Mersner, Jay Gibson, and the Gibbon on the screen. I do think these are your main clients that takes care and that has been taken care by Shivani for all the technical support. Is it so? And I would like to ask if Vincente is also working on the same,
So when I had a discussion along with him, so I do think he's working on most on the SOC and the project tickets. Is it so, Alex and Jim?
Yeah, yeah, we're just getting started, Mohit. We still have a, you know, ramp up training that's going on. So in terms of everybody's working with all clients, we only have a dozen clients that are under contract. So those are the dozen clients that everyone is working on. And if you could, yeah, I mean, we have an abbreviation system for all the clients too. So
Mhm.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
you can utilize that same convention in some of your presentations if you want, which might be preferred because, but yeah, no, that's fine. I mean, you've got the big company names there. Yeah, regarding, you know, tickets as tickets, or I'm trying to get away from actually tickets being the measurement, but
Mhm.
Okay.
Mmh.
Mhm.
for everybody, including Shivani. So I'm not worried about as much about the tickets being a measuring stick as some other things in the future.
So Alex, when we initially started all of the things, so there were a lot of things like PCD and other value drivers as well that were going to be actually the utilization part of the engineer as well. But I do think now you have valuable resources in your team. So I do think the impact that they are going to make, then it will be more clear for us as well and for you as well to showcase like.
how it's going to be done.
Does that make sense? Right. Because before this, we were only focusing on the utilization part. I'll say, you know, with the calendar and the tickets that were being cated right at the spot. And those were the utilization measure. But now I do think with the value addition as well, we'll be able to justify, like, what should be the scale for an engineer, that how much value they are providing.
Yes, yeah.
Mhm.
each and every day.
So we'll make a clarification with that. I'll have a session along with Aman, Vincent, and Animesh with you so that we have a clarity on that. And we can also measure all of the metrics on our side as well.
Yes.
OK.
So if I talk about the issue type that she's been catering to, 15% of them are hardware setup related, 55% most of them are related to access and security, and 30% regarding applications and software. So these are the top three categories or the value drivers of the resolution that she's been providing.
Moving on to the next one, if I talk about the operational stand, so strong baseline efficiency with more than 70% of the utilization. I know that we are, we don't have that baseline for like this much be the threshold for this, but yes, we do see an average for more than 70%. The context switching with all of the clients, we do see.
different deliverables on hardware, support on software, and access and security as well. And rapid resolution. We do see the tickets being closed in less than two days for each and every client and the ticket raised. But yes, any feedback on these kind of service deliverables from your side, Jim, would be really appreciable.
Yeah, I don't know about tickets being closed on an average of two days. I actually mentioned to Shivani and Vincent this morning that they're leaving, you know, they're leaving tickets open that are clearly completed. They're confident they're completed, just waiting.
Mhm.
Mm.
Being for a response from the customer, and we do have a framework around that, which was clarified this morning, so we should be getting those completed.
more efficiently.
Okay, I would like to ask a question and extend my support as well on that. So if we talk about the ticket auditing, is it done by you, Jim or Alex? Do you do that by yourself?
I'm just basically, I it's what I see as I as I'm monitoring the board, so it's not a specific audit, but yeah, it's.
Okay, so Alex, I would like to hear it from you if you require any assistance regarding the ticket auditing as well on the same part because we do have auditing team with us as well. That's the QA team. If we need the support, we can do that as well. Or apart from that, if there is any other way that you would like to help, just let us know.
Well, so, okay, I haven't gone through ticket specific handling training for Vincent and therefore you want to know anyway. Also, nor have I done so without a match, so I wouldn't expect the handling to be anything around
Yeah.
Mhm.
Right.
you know, what our past instructions have been. In terms of what I've seen Shivani doing, I haven't seen any problems. Also, two days would not be a good resolution time. Anyway, in a lot of cases, you know, a lot of resolution times are going to be a lot shorter than that.
Mm.
And.
Probably, and I, you know, and then Shivani's probably doing that just fine because I have been observing Shivani's work and I don't see any issues in that regard. She may not be updating, you know, Jim, you know, Jim may be accurate in saying that she's not necessarily updating them as quickly as she should.
Yeah, then.
as well as even updating them in general.
Dhiman.
They actually make a missing assumption in terms of updating them. I don't necessarily think that the client issue isn't addressed.
Rick.
Agreed.
You know, so.
So yeah, so that's that. And also, I have noticed that her calendar, I sent her a big congratulations last week. I sent her screenshots of her own calendar for three weeks, reflecting that she's doing what we asked regarding.
Mmh.
updating her time, time entries accurately. And that was a really...
Mhm.
you know, it's completely different than it was a couple of months ago and it's, you know, so it's completely done correctly. So she's doing a great job with that. So regarding regarding auditing tickets, we don't need you to audit tickets. You know, I think we're fine in that regard. And we're going to be making some changes regarding how the tickets flow.
Thanks.
No.
Mhm.
with using ConnectWise workflows. You know, I was actually talking to Aman earlier today, they talked, you know, some, you know, well, we can use AI too, like we can use AI to assign tickets, but we can also utilize very simple workflows and ConnectWise to assign tickets.
Right.
We don't even necessarily need anything that sophisticated. We can simply have those tickets automatically assigned as they come in, potentially as a round robin or specific to the board, whatever the case may be.
Mm.
Mhm.
Right, right.
Okay, thank you very much, Alex, for your candid review and feedback on Shivani as well. There was a reason I raised this topic because I understand because sometimes what happens, people are adhering to the process, but in between when there are like, you know, gaps in between like vacations or anything, when they come after that, you know, to rely with the process. So there might be some...
procedure that they must adhere to regularly and that being checked on daily basis like on by auditing of the ticket and all that so that makes a cadence for service as well. So that was my only suggestion in that case. But yes, please feel free if you need any assistance from our side, we'll be glad to help you on that.
Moving on to the next slide, uh, that's...
That sounds good. That sounds good, Mohit. I sort of, again, like you said, I'm sleepy. So I think you said, you mentioned people going on vacation. You said people go on vacation. What were you saying? They go on vacation and then, you know, and you know, you need somebody auditing tickets. That happens in gaps. When you start, when you said those words, I
Yeah.
No issues, no issues. I'll...
So sometimes the gap happened.
My ears perked up a little bit. So wait, wait, gaps? I don't like gaps. So yes, we want to make sure all the gaps are covered.
Yeah, but...
Yeah, so it's human tendency to not to follow things, you know, after they have been, you know, somewhere around or, you know, if there were a lot of tickets and then they didn't adhere to the usual processes. So that's what we want to capture and, you know, to reduce.
And, and...
Very good. Yeah, sounds great. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Alex. So the next slide is about the informational site. It's about the services that we provide. It's about MDE. You're also aware about each and everything. But yes, I'll stop the sharing on this and I would like to hear it from you. What are your plans? What are the things that's going on? And what
Do you need assistance with promising?
Well, well, I spoke with Ronald today about the next steps of, you know, talent acquisition. I spoke to Aman also today regarding, you know, specialized projects, assignments, and tasks to, you know, engineering on demand teams.
Yeah.
Mhm.
you know, which is a very good thing that we wanted to, we started talking about doing with you a few months ago, which we will also utilize. So,
Mm.
Yeah.
Okay, that's great to know, Alex. Anything from Jim or Karrow?
I just want to say, like, Shivani's attitude is fantastic. You can tell she's always, you know, attacking her tickets and really trying to do a good job and she doesn't hesitate to reach out if she needs assistance with something. Yeah, her attitude's awesome.
Sure, thank you very much, Jim. For this, if you could just shoot out a mail to me, that will be really appreciable so that I can share these things with the management as well so that they can appreciate her on those parts.
Sure.
Okay, ladies and gentlemen, with this I do think we are good to wrap up, but anything from anyone?
Nope.
Okay. Thank you very much for joining the call today. I wish you a great week and a weekend ahead.
All good.
You too.
Yeah, thank you. I like the little, I like, I like all your charts. They were all very, very, very cool looking.
Thanks, Mohit.
Kip.
Very, very nice, very nice. Good information. Well done.
Thank you very much. You know, I sent out like the last three reviews for you. I marked them, but I don't think that you have reviewed them. When you asked me to give these service decks, I did it from the very starting. I was expecting you to be on those calls, but...
Smedness queue, Athens on.
Today is the day when you appeared. So thank you very much for that as well.
Well, you know, I will review the previous next as well, I promise.
That will be great. Thank you very much, Alex. Thank you. Have a great day. Bye-bye.
Okay, thank you. I appreciate it. Thank you. All right, bye-bye.
Thanks, everybody.
Thank you.